bea
日本に来て驚いたことはと聞かれたら僕は決まってクリスマスと答える
自分は日本に長年住んでいるがいまだにクリスマスは謎だ
考えるだけでエッグ農具を飲みすぎたような気分になる
ブーブーまずクリスマスの定義が必要だ
クリスマスキリストの降誕言わ
むっつり12月25日に行われるキリスト降誕祭
キリストイエスとますまつりだからクリスマスたよって普通教会に行ったり十字架や
天使をツリーに飾ったりして何らかの形でキリストの降誕を祝って過ごす人が多い
しかし日本にはクリスマスを祝う人が多いのにキリスト教信者をほとんどいない
そう日本のクリスマスは恋人のための単なるますだけだ
僕はこのますの習慣の中に特に気になるものが3つほどある
っつーアメリカの代表的なクリスマスソングというと
へしっで
kare wa ni ore
[音楽]
とかが挙げられるしかし日本ではこれらは無理効かないよく耳にするのはそう
ウェア6の worth クリスでした12月は1日でも日本にいたらこの曲を必ず
聞くと言ってもいいぐらい頻繁に流れている
ででここでなる人が多いと思う僕も長くこの歌を耳にしても特に気にならなかった
構成もいいしバイクル先生の声も素敵
しかし何度も何度も聞いていくうちになんだか体が痒くなってきた
なんか気になるっていう気持ちが少しずつぼやっとした圏央かに変わっていった
なんでこんなにこの
曲を流すなろう
そしてマンで僕はこんなにラスくりすですが嫌になってきたんだろう
自分が聴いて育ったクリスマス村と比較してやっとかゆみの原因がわかった
me
[音楽]
ええええええ
へいへい me
nare
ni
[音楽]
そう相手の幸せを願わ数多くの歌を全て無視して彼らは失恋を嘆く唯一の憂鬱な
クリスマス村を代表にしたそう
クリスマスをえもんしたんだ nura can
ペニー chesty で入試べっッパデリカではクリスマスの夜に普段と違った
ちょっと特別な料理を食べる人が多い
それが七面鳥やハムであったりする日本でもマウスの夜にちょっとと
区別な料理を食べる人がいい何を食べるって県妲己のバケツ地域に決まってるだろ
どうやら40年前に七面鳥が見つからず仕方なく唐揚げを食べている外国人を見て
ちゃんつを感じて
kfc はクリスマスにはケンタッキー
っていう広告を出したようだ多少創造戦にかけるし
塩田に思えるがこれがを渡りしたのだ
現在では何十万人もがますにケンタッキーが訪れる1ヶ月前に予約しないとちっ金が
もらえないほど人気であるまあ7免除がないから分からなくもないっていう人がいると
思う
日本ではキリスト教信者は人口の1%にも達しないということ
を思い出すとこの社会現象がたまらなく不思議に思えてくる
逆パターンを考えてみればすぐにわかるはず例えば大豆がないから節分に黒豆を食べて
いるアメリカ在住の日本人を見て
タコベルがう
二月三日にはタコベルという広告を出しそれを見て鬼は外福は内う知らないアメリカ人
が何十万人も確かにそうかもなってなって
二月三日に行列ができるほどタコベルに行くようになり
その現象が50年近く続いたっとか
家にしまーでも日本は昔から柔軟な部分もあるからなってエベルじゃねーよこれ皆さん
原瀧おじさんの催眠術から目を覚ましてください
[音楽]
気付間違ってるよクリスマスは25日だ
はい以上まあ見れば分かるようにますは不思議の習慣が多いアメリカみたいに普通の
やつ持って入れてもらいたいな[ __ ]と中谷奴って夜の空を飛ぶ太ったおじさんとか
煙突にかかる靴下とか
mac の限定のカップとか
ういってみればアメリカも結構不思議な習慣号
ちゃんとの悪口言ったらぶっ殺すからなてシンプルですよ
いろはショップそれをだってジョイ号は
me
雑渡さん貼って0
[音楽]